hello everyone and welcome to the recap
show of the saint louis wrapping and
blitz my name is tatev abrahamian and
i'm going to take you through
highlights of day three so today the
rapid portion of the tournament ended
um but yesterday i got a comment that i
shouldn't give any spoilers of what
happened so
let's dive right into the games and see
how day three went down
so yesterday magnus carlson had a
perfect day winning all his games
and he continued his trick by um
defeating the young already so this was
a ninja
and uh carlson got a pretty good
position
so let's start on move um 16 after
bishop b2
so magnus carlsen takes on d4 rook d8
and he just grabs a pawn so this was a
pretty one-sided game
i just want to show you the ending
because
it's pretty nice the knight d3
attacking the knight and we'll see the
final position and now we see there are
two big threats in the position
and the knight and if you play something
like this which i think is so
funny because you don't really see a
knight getting trapped like this with so
many pieces on the board
and now the knight is a gunner
so a pretty easy win for the world
champion who won four games in
rome and continues to lead the
tournament because he was leading
so a win of course uh guarantees that he
stays
in the lead so the most epic epic game
of the round was between levon arunian
and hikaru nakamura this game was
absolutely wild which
was so much action in this game and
again um
i won't be able to really do it justice
in this um
kind of a recap because this was too
wild of a game
so in this position i think might move
backs to be played whether or not you've
calculated if it's good
so he takes
f5 because there was check made on h7
and d5 which is oh my god
mind-blowing move uh so lemonade
sacrifices a piece and he just plays
perfectly for several moves and both
players actually play perfectly and this
game is just so amazing
and you guys should definitely check it
out at length after
so check takes only four and
again it's very hard for me to just
really break down the position so
there's a very obvious threat
at some point in the air the bishop is
hanging white is down to pieces but
he is trying to attack the king and here
hikaru plays
an amazing movie takes d5 which is kind
of crazy because he leaves the bishop
hanging
but at the same time he has these
bishops covering
key squares because the last thing you
want to happen is
the rook lens on h3 and it's checkmate
so this happened so now we have a
position of ps versus
ps versus three pawns
so i will just go forward
and this 94 was uh this part was
actually a mistake here by hikar
uh by aronian because after check
he lost the pawn and
um now uh we enter this end game
and again uh i'm kind of going to go
through it a little bit fast because
this is very hard for me to analyze in
the recap video because there's just so
much to this position
so the engine just keeps saying that
black is doing well bike is close to
winning
and big edge but he car had to play
perfectly too in this game so kudos to
him
so now we're going to see how these
white pawns are just starting to move
forward
so there's going to be some kind of a
pawn race
and i really like this setup because the
bishop is untouchable
so pushing the pawns
and unfortunately these pawns are going
to get blocked because we also have a
knight and the king alone can also block
them
so now we see a blockade
and now we're going to see this white
king enter some kind of
sketchy territories because it looks
like that might be some kind of a mating
net here
even though there's a lot of squares for
the king to go to but we do have a
bishop on night and
rook and this night um it's not a night
this night is
tied down to this pawn
so check so again entering this kind of
suspicious territory
and a really nice final move um
and um
to mention that knight b2 was a problem
because
of bishop c6 and now checkmate
uh so and bishop c6 was not possible to
move before because of this fork so this
was just um
distracting the night away it's a really
amazing concept you know um
both using the pan and
creating a mating net to win so i think
this was an amazing amazing game by
hikaru nakamura
so we had two more decisive results this
round
the game between pantala hari krishna
and jeffrey zhang
so let's um jump to move 58
uh so this was a really nice instructive
night and end game will have
had several instructive games in this
tournament and games in this tournament
and
actually i have seen a lot of
instructive end games in rapid and blitz
which is really interesting because you
know
in a faster time control as you reach
the end of the game you have even less
time so to play
high quality end game is extremely
impressive
because by the time we reach an end game
we're already down on time but
in a rapid and bullets are already down
on time to start with so i'm
always impressed by these games so
knight d4 knight a6
and now we're going to see a domination
of the knight so the knight goes to d3
and unfortunately this knight on the
corner has to go to stop the pawn and
it's not going to survive for
too long
k5 shouldering the king
and king b7 is going to be played and
the knight is trapped
so something like this does not help
and the knight gets dropped so i thought
this was really nice
by antala hare krishna
and our final decisive game of the round
was between alexander krishuk and lanier
dominguez
and this was a um pawn end game and
again just goes to show how difficult
land games are and
as i mentioned by the time you get to an
end game you have so little time and
it's so easy to make mistake even by a
stronger player
so in this position king e2 was played
which actually
is a mistake the king has to go the
other way
and we have to shoulder okay i can just
make the moves instead of errors
and we can just go this way and push the
king back
so for example so the king cannot really
get too adventurous because
we'll just force it back
so there is uh there is no avoiding the
inevitable so for example just to show
you how this game would transpire
something like this and f4 and
we're just going to win this pawn so
instead he went k2 which um
looks like a natural move right so f5
was played
so now he goes king d3 king d5 so they
try a couple of moves
so they're repeating the position
and qf-1 is played so greece shook again
trying to
enter from this side and uh there comes
a blunder by dominus which is really
unfortunate again this kind of losses
are so heartbreaking because you feel
like
you're finally done you defended
everyone uh the king had to go back and
the idea is basically you're waiting to
meet your opponent's king so if they go
this way you go this way
so because g4 is always just a drafter
they exchange
and if the king goes this way
yeah we're ready to meet the king so
unfortunately he went king d4
and he was just a few tampi too short
and this end game is just a loss because
covering the e5 key square
the kink uh even if the king made it to
e6 or f6 we
would be able to shoulder it and just
win the pawn so i thought both of these
end games are really instructive and
just goes to demonstrate that
and games are always always difficult
and even the top players go
make mistakes and the final game between
nippon nachi and wesley so was a draw
so let's move on to round eight the
penultimate round so this round was
action-packed so yesterday we saw that
yanni pontochi lost
miniature to jeffrey zhang in the second
game of the round and today he again he
lost a
very quick game this time to lanier
dominguez so this game was very quick so
let's take a quick look
so we've seen a lot of carl cons in this
um tournament
so we're not here to talk about the
opening
but let's just see everything that went
wrong for him
and now h4 and i really like this um
sacrifice
h4 harass is the knight so he decides to
take
but now things are getting really tough
because with a knight on d6 it's hard to
survive and um
dominguez decides not to even bother
taking the rook he decides to go after
the king
so knight h3 ignoring the check
now the knight on h3 is actually trapped
and nowhere to go
and bishop d5 and ending the game on a
really nice note of just simply
capturing
and um again after check after recapture
okay let's make a move this knight is
also trapped
so um not ideal to lose two pieces like
this i thought it was a really really
nice game by dominguez
who uh bounced back from his last round
last
um so there were two more this um
actually one more decisive game in this
round
but um okay so the game between uh
magnus carlsen and jeffrey zhang was a
um kind of an up and down game could
have gone either way so in this position
the world champion has this amazing move
so of course
it's possible to take and then we're
thinking okay if we take
take then the knight comes and takes
this pawn too actually
um it doesn't look like it's possible to
stop this
but then if we take a pause and for a
second we realized that there is knight
g6
and there is a really nice checkmate
so instead this happened and again this
move
was not played so rookman 36
and now it's impossible to take the
knight like this
because no one is stopping this pawn
so he takes this way realizing he's
going to lose his knight decides to
destroy his opponent's pawn structure so
the rook goes there
and he starts running with his king and
this was a crucial mistake by the
youngster he should have taken this pawn
instead he decides to cut off the king
probably thinking he can
the f4 pawn but uh this is amazing move
and now we find the king
in a perpetual
and there's just no escape for the king
to get out of this because the g6 square
is taken
um and there's just nowhere to go so
i was very jeffrey looked very
disappointed on camera and
magnus was just laughing after i don't
know it's because he realized he
also missed the win or he's just like
how did i get away with this
but this gave room for his close rival
wesley saw to
get closer by his win over levon aronian
so let's take a look at that game
so wesley saw with the white pieces
we're going to take a look so you see
the final position we'll take a look at
how we got there
he shows the dominance of the bishop
against the knight and bishops can be
really annoying pieces
against knights in the end game and in
all parts of the game too
so king goes to g7 and the king comes in
and now we're going to see
the knight on e8 kind of gets dominated
against the bishop on the 8th
and now there's the threat of playing
i'm taking the spawn
and if something like this
and we can uh king h6 can be met by a
check
and we also can just put a bishop on f4
it's still dominating this knight and
come take this pawn
so instead 11 decides to give up a pawn
just so the knight can move but
unfortunately the knight does not go far
the problem is taking this pawn allows
the king to enter and just take all the
other pawns
so this is looking pretty hopeless
check and f4 and now again i really like
how he's playing
because after pawn was hanging and just
expanded his so there's no rush to
taking it
so now we take the pawn and now we're
going to see how this knight
and this is very annoying just remember
this kind of a setup of
a night on the edge and a bishop like
this
um completely dominating the night and
actually here he resigned because the
pawn is just going to queen and there's
not much to do
so we entered the last round with magnus
carlsen
a full point ahead of wesley saw so
in this round magnus carlsen is playing
against alexander gruischuk
so this was a wild game he chose the
dragondorff
which is a combination of a dragon and a
i'll show you
dragon and a nightdorf not a very common
opening
but grishik was expecting some
adventures from magnus
uh so let's jump to her key moment in
this game which
is move 19 when magnus carlsen
just decides to take on c3 very common
sacrifice uh in the sicilian
but um did not pan out too well here
because krishuk finds this amazing move
bishop a5
and the queen is just going to
infiltrate on the diagonal
d5 and the queen comes in and just takes
a pawn
so fearless all kinds of threats are
going to happen
that might land on c5
that goes to c7 and just takes another
pawn
the knight and the queen capturing all
the pawns on the queen side
forcing a trait and he goes on to
demonstrate
pretty flawless technique to win this
end game
and the pawns start rolling
so it was very long time chris shook
that is and which is pretty common for
him if you ever
followed his games he always gets low on
time
but his play was just perfect
and here magnus carlsen decides to
resign because
this pawn this pawn is just not going to
leave for too long
and by too long i mean for another move
so once we take this pawn there is not
enough counter play
and uh very likely this pawn will also
gonna fall so there's just way too much
material
so now this gives the opportunity for
wester so to catch him
and once i click on this you are going
to know
whether that happened or not so wesley
so did manage to win his game against
pentaho krishna and actually leapfrogged
wesley so um he lived for magnus carlsen
so wesley so is now winning the
is leading the tournament he won the
rabbit portion so
congratulations to him on a phenomenal
performance so let's take a look at this
game
but this was another great end game of
night versus night so we're seeing a lot
of night end games here
uh let's jump to the position where this
trade happened
and we see how this king compared to
this king this knight
is too far away from action so the king
starts to come in
and the pawns are just falling
and the problem is black is playing with
two pieces and white is playing with one
takes the pawn
stopping any kind of 95 checks takes the
pawn
uh
losing end game so that's a pretty um
pretty funny way of defending the pawn
like defending it tactically
so instead h4 is played h5 is played so
the knight comes in and again
just entering a losing endgame
so instead king a3 but now the king
comes in
so giving up the pawn
f4 another amazing move and just taking
everyone
and these puns are just unstoppable just
too many of them
a knight alone doesn't do well with too
many puns cannot can barely even stop
one pawn
uh so really great technique by wesley
saw so again congratulations to him for
winning the rapid portion and leading
the tournament so tomorrow is going to
be
the first day of blitz so there's going
to be 9 9 rounds of blitz so it's going
to be action-packed
so they're in the rabbit portion the
winds were worth two points and in the
blades portion there was
one point so this was twice as much
because there's only nine rabbit games
in 18 blitz games
uh so tomorrow anything can happen with
nine games all it takes is one day
one bad day for uh everything to go
wrong or one good day for everything to
go right
so make sure um you're checking out usgs
champs to
take a deeper look at the games we just
went over and make sure you're tuning in
tomorrow on san luis's
youtube channel or on usgs champs to
check out day one of blitz
thanks guys for checking this out and
see you tomorrow